[Music]
with news that a vaccine might be around
the corner
you ethical questions are on the horizon
who will get it first how much will it
cost
[Music]
will the rich or poor be first in line
or the most vulnerable like this woman
here
she's living in a bomb shelter because
of the armenian azerbaijani conflict
[Music]
and covert is running rampant in these
tight quarters
or should doses go to frontline workers
who put their lives on the line
like here at a testing station in
frankfurt
questions remain especially on the news
that brazil has suspended
its trial of a chinese candidate vaccine
there are no easy answers
welcome to the show all this week we're
talking vaccines and covert 19.
on monday news broke that there could be
a vaccine by the end of the year
america's pfizer and germany's biontech
were first to announce successful data
from a large-scale
clinical trial of a coronavirus vaccine
they say it's more than 90 percent
effective
but we're not going to be able to rely
on just one vaccine to inoculate the
world
and then came the unfortunate news
brazil's health regulator
has stopped clinical trials of china's
coronavac
organizers at the trial say there was a
death but that it was not related to the
vaccine
let's touch on those developments with
henry vodka's professor of bioethics
near ayat
near if that were the result of the
death were
linked to the trial how ethical would
that make it
the ethics of a trial doesn't depend on
whether something bad happens with trial
trials there is risks just like in
clinical care the trials should
work to minimize those risks in advance
and if
everything was done to keep that risk
minimal
that wouldn't necessarily indicate any
ethical problem the design of the trial
but uh participants here being exploited
i don't think so uh they are being
offered
a deal that is perfectly reasonable to
take uh
they are recruiting in areas of high
transmission of coverage a very
dangerous disease that can kill and
is killing many people in those areas
they are taking risks because
uh unlike the people who will use this
vaccine
after it's been proved safe in these
large populations um
this is still experimental they are
still checking on the safety they're
still
checking on the efficacy but um
it's a it's a gamble if you will that is
reasonable to take
and therefore a very fair offer i think
to the drop at this point
we mentioned one corona vaccine being
very successful one less successful
there
are hundreds in development right now
but what is the most ethical way of
testing a more promising one and a less
promising one
you know we don't know that which
vaccine is successful at this time
it's it's a bit like uh calling the
elections uh after half an hour
of results pouring in things still will
change um
but um still when there are signals that
one vaccine might be
more promising than another it may be
tempting to say
oh it's not okay to compare them anymore
to each other because we're offering
the people who are getting that at that
point less promising vaccine
a less promising alternative but
remember it's really like the elections
um
it is very nice just briefly
why is it important to test vaccines on
on the continent or country in which
they're to be used
well um it's actually very important for
that country
and its populations not only is it fair
towards uh
the participants and their families who
get potentially protected by the vaccine
if it works
it's also important for the inhabitants
of that country to know
this vaccine was tested in people like
us who have our
nutritional and environmental and maybe
even genetic um
characteristics um and it will also
help that country i think in the
negotiations later about which country
will be getting the vaccine if it's
proven
efficacious so it's actually very
valuable for a country
to be a test site for vaccine trials
okay neil stay where you are we'll
return to you later in the show
first of all biontech and pfizer have
sparked a surge of
optimism but the unsung heroes of this
tale
are the thousands of unpaid volunteers
taking part in clinical trials
many in latin america however it's not
clear when
latin americans will actually get the
vaccine
in sao paulo biontech researchers have
already tested the vaccine on hundreds
of people
either with an active ingredient or
placebo latin america is one of the
world's main vaccine testing grounds
largely in brazil volunteers are not
allowed to talk to the media
they're unpaid for many of the
attraction is that they will at least be
vaccinated by taking part
our test subjects are not just health
workers they're also ordinary brazilians
who have to get up early to take the bus
or subway for hours to get to work
brazil is the country with the second
most coronavirus related deaths in the
world
do the people here feel like guinea pigs
in a
of course there's a lab that's
unavoidable when testing the vaccine
monday's announcement showed that
biontech's research was more advanced
than any of its competitors vaccines
the german company stressed the test
results were early and still incomplete
will be efficient it will probably be
one of the most important vaccines in
the world
another german pharmaceutical company
curavac is also testing a vaccine in
latin america
in panama the high infection rate among
the population makes it easier to get
speedy results
the panamanians are hopeful that the
cooperation will allow them to
manufacture the vaccine itself later
technology transfer in return for
helping with the testing phase
the fact that panama is working together
with the german vaccine company
certainly gives our country a
competitive advantage over other
countries
kurovak is also testing in peru
for the inhabitants of the poor area
bella vista del mirador
the testing process itself is not the
main issue
for them it's simply about surviving the
pandemic
the people here fear they will once
again be left behind
when it's time for the vaccine to be
given out
i doubt the peruvian government will
provide us with the vaccine here it's
almost impossible we feel forgotten
the now very real prospect of a vaccine
this year is largely due to the
contribution of people like the
residents of bella vista del mirador
but when latin america will get the
vaccine remains unclear
well something else that could speed up
the process of finding a successful
vaccine are human
challenge trials here's derek williams
on that
will other countries do their own
challenge trials now that the uk has
announced it's doing so
challenge trials involve intentionally
infecting
organisms with a pathogen to find out
how well
vaccines or medications work at stopping
that pathogen
they're a fast track method for
determining safety and efficacy and we
conduct them all the time
usually on animals especially primates
but in ethical terms human challenge
studies like the one proposed in britain
can be pretty
charged if the plans are approved
starting this january
researchers there will begin
deliberately infecting
young healthy volunteers with stars cove
2
initially to find out how much of the
pathogen it takes
to make them infected once the
scientists have determined that
they can begin giving other volunteers
vaccines
then subsequently challenging their
immune system with that preset dose
of coronavirus to see how effective the
vaccines are
doing things this way can provide
precise data
quickly so it can really speed up the
development process
that's because instead of just giving a
late stage vaccine candidate to
thousands of volunteers
and a placebo to thousands of others and
then
basically waiting to see what happens
researchers have a lot more control over
the entire process
but they don't have control in one key
area
um because we still don't have surefire
therapies to treat someone
if an induced covet 19 infection turns
severe
the possibility that a human challenge
trial could cause a volunteer
long-term damage or even kill them that
can't be ruled out
despite those risks britain is
apparently not the only country to
consider conducting human challenge
trials
according to the science journal nature
at least some
exploratory planning has commenced in
belgium
and the us as well
and returning to our professor at
bioethics
what's your take on human challenge
trials
i think that child trials quite distinct
from what we've discussed so far which
are regular
field trials challenge trials are
also in my view ethical that's a less
consensus view than
the one that i've expressed earlier
challenge trials
would be acceptable in my own view
because the risks although they exist
remain
lower for mortality than a practice that
everybody accepts such as
live kidney donation only in this case
um we're doing it not just to help one
person but of course with
the informed consent of the person being
put at risk but to help
hundreds and thousands and millions of
people
uh if we can get to a vaccine faster i
think
it's unbalanced justified with the
informed consent of the volunteers
in what ways can they help speed up the
development of a vaccine
in multiple ways in a field trial you're
waiting for people to get
exposed to the virus and that sometimes
doesn't happen
it has not happened in some of the early
trials for
a vaccine to fight coronavirus in the uk
it hasn't happened in the trials of
other types
for coronavirus countermeasures in china
so
if there wouldn't be enough exposure to
the virus
in a regular trial we wouldn't know for
many many months
whether the vaccine protects against the
virus or not in a child trial you simply
deliberately infect people
the flip side of this is that uh you
know that it works both as far as
and you can find within weeks the
results
there are also other things that you can
find out uh you can
you know exactly when you infected them
so you can assess very accurately the
duration of the vaccine protection
you can assess very accurately the exact
mechanism through which the immune
system
protects those in whom the vaccine works
so
it's very very valuable for western
development
bioethics professor niel thanks for
being on the show today
you